Hello, George.
Hi, Natalie, how are you?
I'm doing pretty good.
Yeah.
I think I need it.
some more.
I'm deciding whether I should get an energy drink or a water. And then like, I just didn't get anything. Like I'm looking down, I'm like, oh, I just have my empty Frappuccino here. And I was like, I didn't decide. I was just like, oh, I guess I won't get anything.
It.
But.
Right.
How's everything with you? Have you been traveling at all?
Um, for personal stuff and then I got quarterlies for troop here next week, so just trying to get everything in order so I can disappear for a couple days.
Okay.
Gotcha. What's troop here?
I could say as peer group.
Gotcha, gotcha. Oh yeah, you're not at Kaseya Connect.
No, did not go. No, I don't. No, because I'll go spend money. I can't spend money right now.
No, no.
Right. How do you like Troupeer? I have another client who's in that as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, I really like it. I've never done any kind of peer group, so it's my first. So I would take what I have to say with a grain of salt because I have a good comparison, but I like it. I like the pod that I'm in and the group of people and it's constructive, supportive, accountable and aggressive when needed.
but not wanted. So it's good. They've got a, Gary Peak has got a good structure with the finance side of things and the numbers that they spit out. And, you know, me, I'm kind of ********** with the numbers, but then I look at other people and they're full-blown into the numbers and they
Okay, alright.
I want to say they run their business off of them, but they definitely let some of the feedback from the Power BI dictate some decisions they make. And I see a lot of success in it. So, you know, and they just got Robin Robin, so, you know, that's way more salesy.
Yeah.
Sales, marketing, you know.
And so, we'll see if they even integrate it. I don't know, so...
Gotcha. Yeah, I saw you were looking at the AI, the masterminds with ITBD. Were you thinking still about doing that? You're coming to build, right?
I would really like to, but I just found out last week that I've got a big, my big whale client is starting the first. They're cutting, they're cutting a very large chunk of money for me, and then they're going to continue to do so.
Ohh.
That sucks, yeah.
So it's one of those things I can try and hold them to the contract, and then they're just, you know, they'll either fight it or move along. And so I just got to kind of accept it. But they're looking to move more towards automation and stuff. And so I was going to talk to Anderson about that, and obviously you, because they think better than having them write the check, I'll
Daum.
Charge them less money per seat, but charge them.
Yeah, we can look at this like an AI managed services contract type deal.
Yeah, either, yeah, something like that, or you know, where we, because really like password resets and onboarding and offboarding, so I think AI is a heavy term for that. It's more automation since it's predictable processes, and so, and so...
I think if I were to invest in that and then turn around and say, hey, it's X amount of dollars per seat to utilize this, I'll come out ahead. And then obviously they wouldn't own anything, any of the proprietary stuff. So I kind of get a little hook in there as well.
Yeah, no, for sure, for sure. Yeah, but definitely then, if you want, before you have that conversation too, I can see if like Sunny is available as well to help guide that, because those are the type of conversations that will come up in like our peer groups.
I know they're talking a lot about IP in that strategy as well.
Yeah, that's my, it's not, I'm not concerned about utilizing it and reducing our hours, but they've got a mentality that correlates very directly to what we do for them and labor hours. And so how do I, I have to change that perception and I've got to, yeah, I can't just open the door to AI and say, yeah, go do this and do that and work with IT by design. And then
Yeah, I know.
Gotcha.
No.
****, now they have everything they need in my mouth, so...
No, no, but I, but I think that's the goal is to figure out how do we keep it monthly reoccurring product, right? And then I also think too, people don't realize like it's more of like a time saved for the human that that goes into it and not so much like replacing.
Yeah.
things and then even with IT as well, like there still needs to be that human intervention. So it's just figuring out and just getting things done quicker, right? It's in the, it's, hey, we're getting this done quicker and then figuring out what that looks like, right? But you're still managing it, things still break.
It's all technology.
Yep, yep, for sure.
Hey, Akhilesh.
Hey, Natalie, hey George, how are you?
Good, how are you doing?
Good, good. Is it the regular service call that we are meeting for or is it like an ad hoc one?
Yeah, this one's a weekly one.
Okay.
Is this a week? I'm like, I don't know. I missed, I missed you guys on Friday. I was driving and where I was in Texas. So if you know Texas, there's a lot of nothing in places. So including, I always just went to Austin. We drove down from Denver.
Yeah.
No, I was like...
Yu.
Ohh.
Yeah, well, part. I'm in Dallas. Jeez.
Okay, yeah, yeah, there's a, well mostly I feel like Kansas would be the desolate area, right?
So.
Yeah, yeah, we came down through like Amarillo and the Panhandle. And so, yeah, when you're in between, you're in between. Did you get hit by the tornadoes out there?
Yeah.
No, they were saying that there was like hail and stuff yesterday where I'm at because I'm a little north of Dallas. So I didn't personally have anything, but yeah, I've definitely been here where I've been working and the tornado sirens go off. So it's like one of those things because I'm not originally from here. I'm from Pennsylvania.
Okay.
So like it's one of those things as I've moved to Texas, I've lived here for about 6 years now.
Cats just knocking over stuff. I've lived here for about 6 years now. Like that's one of the adjustments that I've made. It's only annoying. Like the hail is probably the most annoying piece of it. I say that not having run into an actual tornado, but like the hail is like what I'm always worried about. My car is going to get stuck somewhere.
Yeah.
Just got dance on.
Well...
Yep, okay, so Aman is here. I was just filling in. So, George, how is it going with the business side and how the engineers are performing as of now?
Well, I just dropped Anderson a little bit of a bomb. I am Natalie, but I'm losing some business over here. And so I'm in a little bit of a scramble to figure out where I can save. I think one immediate place is going to be Seguna's role.
And probably I'm asking you guys what contract terms were on and what that looks like from a commitment standpoint if I can get out from under that. And I'm thinking everything should be fairly short term. I've got Dave's been working on my team has been working through sales stuff since January and he's
catching some traction now. And so I would anticipate that hopefully our sales funnel will start filling up and we'll start turning some clients and then we can re-engage for that second resource. Right now I need to look everywhere I can. I've gotten rid of my fractional CFO. I'm looking at Saguna. I'm looking to get rid of another.
Um...
another employee or two on my end just slim down for the time being while I have to. So from a business side of things, it's not great.
But surroundable.
Yeah, and then you said that there is a certain pipeline as well, which you are targeting because of sales is concerned.
Yeah.
It's small right now. It hasn't produced much on a prospect level, except for like the last week, started booking more first time appointments and stuff like that. So it's starting to turn into some actionable meetings versus busy work like it was before.
Okay. But yeah, hopefully it will just turn over and get to the smoother version once again. Okay.
Yeah, awesome.
So for Saguna, and it may come up in this, just because I'm not super familiar, what's the scope of work right now? And then George, would your idea be to look at the existing scope of work of Saguna and see if there's any automation that we can build into what they're currently working on?
Well, I think Anderson may be able to shed some light, because I think...
Scope of works really tier one, tier 2. It's pretty standard reactive support. I don't think Noel and Seguna are fully utilized, or at least to the point that they could be right now. So I think there's some bandwidth for Noel to pick things up.
Mhm.
App.
And with the reduction in services, the two guys that are here in Colorado are going to have more time to be more efficient. So whereas Jack and Zach were moving around four days a week, not at their desk, that was the advantage of having Nolan and Saguna, they're going to be back at their desks.
Um...
all but one, maybe two days a week. And so they're going to have the capacity to kind of already pick up some of what Seguna was doing. From an automation standpoint, this big client that is reducing their cost, the two biggest line items that we do support-wise for them are password resets and onboarding and offboarding.
And Natalie, before everyone got on, we were kind of talking and I emailed Anderson, you know, I want to talk about what it would look like to get some automation around password resets, both by email and by phone. Yeah, because
The door, door.
So, right, so in theory, someone can't access their, they can't access their computer, so they don't have email, even though we have it on our phones, but let's say they don't. Just being able to pick up the phone, this is the company I'm with, or this is my company code. I need to reset my password, this is my name, and then I need the system to push out a dual authentication.
and validate that MFA, and then provide the temporary password, set that, and allow the password to be reset. And so, I mean, it's really sad that that's most of our work is resetting passwords, but this client wants to automate as much as possible to reduce the human interaction.
So that's one place. And the second is onboarding and offboarding. And Natalie, like I said, it's really predictable processes. It's, this is the name, this is the location, this is the position. And then from there, it populates what applications are needed and in what order. And it's not very many. So we can build out that workflow.
automate onboarding, automate offboarding.
And, um, you know, that one will be a little bit later down the line, but the password reset they're looking to do sooner than later, so...
Yes, there's automation we can put in a place that would replace a bit of what Sagun is doing, and then that would allow Noel and the team here to pick up the other, you know, the odd application and one-off stuff that maybe is not quite as predictable.
Thank you, George, for the information. Yeah, I think I'm already aligned with the Entra 81. So already prepared, then the discovery part, you know, and the scope of work is already ready. So I'm just going to review that final before I send it over to you. Let the second piece is about the auto task contract. So I'm going to work on that today. A few information I was just looking.
Okay.
how they want to build. I think earlier the one we created, right, that is good with that. So this is separate apart from that.
Yeah, yeah, you got me the chart of accounts in there and then what all I need to do now is I need to get the bundles set and then I need to, there's about.
Yeah.
I want to say they told me 120 and six, so there's about 170, 180 contracts that need to be built in. 160 or 150 of those are going to be voice over IP. So they're going to be real straightforward and basic. This many seats,
It's really seats, faxing, and maybe a couple odd things. But yeah, we, so those, most of those will be easy, but I don't need, I'd like if you quoted me out on doing the actual work, I would get you access to our Tiger Paul and I'd get you access to our Blue Billing or two separate systems that we'll bring together.
I'll get you access to that so you can see the contracts. But, you know, if my team needs to do it, that's fine. I've got Rodney and Stephanie can probably do that if need be. But I also want to move quickly because I'm paying Tiger Paul. It's creating a mess on my accounting side of things. So there's costs involved in it already and it's creating a headache for me.
No, no, definitely. I can work on that side. So I will definitely review the current setup that you have on the auto task and kind of prepare a plan. Then I can discuss with either with you or with the team. So if I need any further information and I can share the scope of work for that too. And yeah, the last piece about the automation for the password, yeah.
So...
Okay.
Which one?
Okay, wonderful.
I will definitely work with the team and create a kind of plan what would be going to suit as per your environment, how we're going to roll out, what is our suggestion and take your recommendation and then finally can propose a plan, you know.
Okay.
For that, too, Haley.
Hey, Lee.
Hey everybody, George. Hadn't seen you in a while, so I figured I'd jump on. How you been?
I know. Thank you. Appreciate it. Good, Yu.
Yeah.
Good, good. Am I going to see you in a few months? I'm sure they already brought up Build It.
Yeah, no, no, not right now. I'm on a spending freeze pretty hard, back trying to save more than spend.
I hear you. I hear you. No, no worries at all. I'll just make a point of jumping on to these every once in a while and I can see your face, hear your voice. Say hello.
Awesome. Appreciate it.
Absolutely.
So I think yeah, these three to do in my list. Yeah, I think we I'm in plan for the upcoming service call on Friday to discuss about the deck and everything. So this is just formal information. I want to gather that for all these things. So I'll get back to you if I need any further information or anything related to any of this task and.
Okay.
Propose you the final scope of work for all three.
Okay, and the entry ID, when you send that over today or tomorrow, I'll give it a look. If I have questions, I'll let you know. But that's project work, so don't expect me to turn around right away. I'll need to go to the client and get confirmation on that.
No, yeah, yeah, that's kind of the initially follow up. So if they need to make any changes, anything in the scope of work, yeah, do let me know so I can further modify that.
Wonderful.
Khan.
I think that's what we have. Ellie, I already forwarded you one email, which George already discussed, but yeah, I forwarded you that email too.
Yeah, my only question there, George, so no issues as far as Seguna. I know it was a flex agreement, so you were kind of gauging what the business was going to look like. Just want to make sure that we're helping you support the client. So what he mentioned, Aman, as well as like that the client still in.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
You.
Daum.
contract. So he's trying to figure out like how do we, how are we still going to make this active revenue right at the end of the day. So we'll continue to work strategically there. But what would we want the last working day for Seguna to be then? Normally we like to get 30 days, but we'll start throwing.
Yeah.
her in the interviews.
That's.
That's fine. Yeah, 30 days is fine. And if you need to take him sooner, I'd be very flexible with that. So if he starts interviewing right away, that's fine by me. And if you tell me tomorrow, got somebody for him, then so be it. We'll be good.
So yeah, I can do the 30 days. So end of May. I do still have an outstanding bill with you guys. I've previously been emailing. I will get it paid. I'm not going to let it go undone, just so everyone's on the same page.
Yeah, she'll show up at your house. She's wild.
Yeah, I've heard so.
But.
And that's a heavy flight too, so.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, let's do, let's do the 30 days, but please feel free to start interviewing him and that should be good. Then hopefully there's not a transition period on a bench that sucks.
Ohh.
Yeah, for sure, for sure. And then just as far as feedback, any coaching opportunities like as we realign as well for the next onboarding?
Under.
I, you know.
I feel bad saying no because that doesn't give you anything to work with.
I think the good is that every time I was like, hey, you know, maybe let's step it up a little bit and try something new, there wasn't a lot of hesitancy. I would say I probably more likely had to come to you guys and ask that we push him a little bit, whereas Noel kind of self-advocated and did it on his own.
But that's also a comfort level thing. And I think too, he's representing IT by design, so you don't want to overstep, make an error and then get yelled at. So you can't blame him too much for that. But no, I think the flexibility and the willingness to learn have been awesome.
You know, we kind of talked about replacing his position anyway with a different tiered tech. I don't know, Natalie, if you were part of that or caught wind of it, but kind of just looking at the business things over here before last week. And so the only reason we would have moved
Rana.
directions with him is just for a higher tier of, you know, maybe more networking knowledge and stuff like that, but nothing from like a serviceability side of things. I mean, he's been, I hit him yesterday, hey guys, can someone call this client? I think it had been 5 minutes, but of course, then the client texted me and they're like, it's an emergency.
He was already on the phone with him. So I just, I don't have any, I don't have anything better that he can do except keep learning.
No, that's great. That's great. Yeah.
No, no, no problems. We'll definitely start the realignment and then too, we'll do a knowledge transfer, right, since Noel, I mean, Noel's going to be taking over the majority of the work as well. So.
over here, Noel and my two guys, well, three guys, they do a really, really good job of communicating, keeping everything in IT glue. And so hopefully that, I'm not joking, I think they communicate good enough that you could drop the bomb on me and he could be gone the next day. I don't think we're going to trip over ourselves.
So, um, they've all that both those guys in my team have been really good at it.
Keeping in communication, so...
Good, good, good.
And it, and and George, I think the uh skill set that you share, you know, we we're still gonna look for that particular which you shared.
Let's put a pause on it right now. Let me score a couple wins over here, and because if I get if I just get two or three more contracts, which I don't see out of the realm in the next four-ish months, then I'll probably be looking back to, I really enjoyed the structure of having IT by Design as our as kind of our Helpdesk.
And so I definitely want to keep that structure and run with it.
Love to hear.
Glad to hear it.
Yeah, and I know you were talking with, you know, sharing it with Natalie, but George, thank you for the perspective on overall performance. I'm glad to hear it was nothing, you know, there's no, nothing service related that's driving the decision.
And.
No, not at all.
The.
Little.
All right. Well, I know that you guys will have a separate meeting, but yeah, I'll stay in touch and I'll let you know if anything else pops up and they'll keep you informed, like if we are putting Seguna into an interview and just make sure that the tickets are being watched and we'll have you.
Yes, think.
Yeah.
Perfect. I appreciate it, guys. Thanks for understanding.
Good to see you, George.
Thank you. See you later.
Kris.
Thank you, Jars.
Thank you. Take care.
Take care.
Cheers.